you
hey why not alright this is a
last-second entry hurry up here I'll
link it really quick in the chat hurry
up
enter here we go hourly bullet arena
last second enter there's only like a
dozen players one answer this one
alright we'll see how many enter
alrighty so let's get developed pinpoint
that guy let's restrict to be for for a
little bit
alright I'm weak on these light squares
Bishop b4 is maybe an idea give a check
I don't like how I'm playing this I
think I want to control this light
square this is a strong move all right
let's get my knight into this square hmm
don't like how implying this Knight into
e six dropping up on now hmm I wonder
why they didn't take that pawn and down
time kick that night away
that night he's really strong gonna win
this pawn its defend hmm I guess we take
no let's take here working my king up
let's back up I'm gonna grab that pawn I
get their Bishop hmm this is a passed
pawn get here get out of that pin as
soon as possible
oh boy got I'll go into a pin now oh oh
I'm in a pin
I'm also down on time back to tournament
ooh a lot of people entered okay shake
that one off man shake it off okay you
got a fight back no no fries revenge is
up there no no fries revenge
some of you viewers are funny who
remembers good old Nonna fry get out of
there
shoo there we go he's gone astray dark
squares or maybe sensitive maybe I'm
just gonna anchor a night here they're
gonna kick it away I'm gonna allow them
to take it feels like my computer's
crawling just a little bit I'm gonna
take that guy give me the H file Queen
here move the knight take on h6 hmm I
get the H file this should be leading to
mate yeah let's check it's just
or stuff right there so I could land a
check and then that checkmate back to
tournament 23rd a lot of time actually
now these are I always forget these are
the 26 minute tournaments the hourly
bulge arena have four minutes makes a
big difference yeahso all right well
that's third time we're playing no
second time we're playing this is the
total they're gonna move I could use a
quick win all right
they were in the think tank okay they
were doing some last some last-second
opening prep there let's undermine their
center they're not threatening the
bishop just yet mm-hmm I like that all
right let's develop let's throw a strike
at the Bishop Bishop a6
okay I'm winning some material now I
could pinpoint the night he goes to b5
eirick is unprotected let's not forget
about that clean has to go to see to I
guess take the rook and then take the
bishop okay I'm getting I'm getting
everything now clean trade that's me
that was a pretty quick one I'll take it
back to tournament four yeah I've said
it before if you're gonna lose a game
that first one is the one to lose all
right let's see if it could be a little
bit crazy
the
more dynamic is what I really meant to
say okay let's go here at my dark square
Bishop breathe just look to hunt down
this pawn
how are you stopping this idea hmm
well he's gonna jump in here mm-hm
that wasn't a good idea on Bishop c5 I
have a timely b4 okay that Knight has to
give himself up I guess we'll take with
the King here King G to get my rook to
the e-file what's up with that bishop
where are you going man yeah he's not
scaring me let's have a more aggressive
post for my Bishop f4 seems like a nice
square let's connect rooks gonna give me
the H file it could step up my king here
rook on h8 incoming I guess the King has
to run to d7 hmm where's the bishop
going he's in a pin no I should just
take and then look to ya have Knight
here to block and then Bishop backing up
how did they stop Queen takes bishop
can't do that stay on the Bishop Bishop
b4 as well they're down on time back to
tournament land a chest girl I've read
that as chess giri okay twelve eight
eight because just before the Turman
started
there's talking in the chat here on
Twitch Geary all right Tomic $1.99
plenty of time left only four points
back no one's calling sir no one is
running away with this one yet okay
that's a valuable tempo that's a pawn
all right let's just trade throw a pawn
in the center and complete development
on efficient pair let's point at h2
let's continue pointing at h2 they just
weaken their light squares on their
Kings side I'm a bishop on the main
diagonal open this up they're helping me
to open it up
they are really helping me to open it up
and now I'm winning a piece just
focusing on the weaknesses is netting me
a piece basically prove the king
position let's open up the H file how
about that yeah made on each one yeah
incoming can't really stop it
that's a matin - you have to play Bishop
d8 it's a pretty fast one those light
squares as soon as that Jeep on moved my
my eyes lit up
- those light squares and my opponent
didn't have a light square bishop so it
made a lot of sense to immediately get
that Bishop on the long diagonal it
doesn't get much better than that when
you have a an unopposed bishop and your
opponent is weak on that color the light
squares in that case they didn't have a
light square bishop and they were weak
on the light squares near their king it
spell disaster really quick okay Knight
g4 might hit no Bishop here I got there
dark square bishop and maybe the
exchange yes rook is pinned don't take
pin pieces move you up a full rook they
might resign I'm gonna play this one out
mmm
clean exchange let's just take I took
the pin piece in that case but because
otherwise Knight d4 let's just trade
kick this night out yeah it's a little
bit annoying drop back and I here let's
undermine this point and trade yeah
let's just keep it really simple
really simple like I almost just Mouse
lip there
let's take and I have h1 covered so the
rook can't get active got ahead of
myself there I was overly excited about
tracking down that a pond huh
all right I'll take him yeah they're
really just no pickle can't really do
anything and let's get this guy going a
little bit and now I could improve my
king position you should probably move a
little bit faster a little faster keep
on pushing all right and got this they
resigned back to tournament 2016 all
righty efore less than 1500 it's a free
piece I guess they were expecting Knight
f3 might resign no they're not resigning
all right
and then here they might target c2 I
might do something ugly like Bishop d3
okay now it's not as bad night before
here I'm not obstructing my D pawn yeah
I don't know let's go here I don't want
to allow some play against the D file or
my deep on okay they just gave up a
really strong night let's stop Queen a3
Castle queenside go here Castle kingside
throw rook on v1 I guess I have six is
coming let's prepare for that let's just
take right away get a flight square in
I'm on the night where is he going
I guess h4 h4 g4 g5 there we go
Queen g4 rook to e1 or rook to e8 yeah
let's check
it's another check I guess here pile up
on that pin piece 95 Knight h4 mmm
that's collapsing for sure mm-hmm
let's take this is running it to mate
clean here next and that's mate
factor tournament 24 2016 16 13 less
than 13 minutes left chess girl 94 still
up there pelvic Arclight okay let us see
mmm
nan mover no we got a mover we have
ourselves a mover all right get out
there tempo yeah let's continue to chase
him around a little bit more yeah let's
go all in super committal move g4 and
they're ready oh no I don't want to give
up my LightSquared bishop so easily
mm-hmm don't like I'm playing this get
that
Bishop out there I need to focus on this
square hmm I'm back here c5 can I get
away with that let's try it a little bit
scary mmm not a good idea look at the
time situation you got to be kidding
can't win with this time Wow oh boy got
to get rid that night oh that's helpful
I got the rook but I don't have any time
can't take that pawn either ah 12
seconds red that night dangerous Forks
there was something better there
I gotta go for time burners no tricky
night he's dangerous
it's all I have
that is all I have is a tricky night I'm
a lot of breath and I won her time oh
man what an ugly game ugliness
where did my time go probably spent it
you know contemplating how I got in such
a bad position like what was I doing
there
hmm all right let's drift over here
secure this Center okay they released
the pressure some let's center break
down there Kings side a little bit with
H form let's keep this file open I I
guess I want to keep the Queen's on now
oh those are almost bad I don't know
let's keep going here
can you to guess so
Oh Knight here why didn't you go there
right away why not right away
let's go here and then just clear this
guy out I want that each to pawn right
there he's past here here and then push
not quite okay move the knight and then
push it's a check can't be stopped now I
got that square cover with my knight
getting a Queen Queen g2 even on time
called they resigned back to tournament
man okay we're tied we're both on fire
is he playing yes go Kovac get him get
him Paco vaq go Oh Oh got him did for
hummock win he won well done oh we're
gonna get paired up
I mean phobic now I won't be cheering
for you
why am I not getting paired up I'm in
I'm not I'm still in there we go okay
now this is the game I want you to lose
pehoe vaq this is the one I want you to
lose I'm not cheering for you yeah all
right Knight c3 all right they have the
H file where's that night going what are
you up to
let's stop this ship d6 hmm play I have
sex I'm going to take that night let's
do that actually their night might end
up being stranded actually it's a cook
tonight I like that take with the pawn I
guess they're gonna try for something
active like Queen g5 or whatever mm-hmm
we're gonna take and I'm playing my
queen and their knight is out of play
and they hear incoming they might resign
yeah I think they're ready to resign
clock situation and being down a piece
they resigned 32 28 28 4 point lead and
I have fire I like it
seven minutes less than seven minutes
remain all right okay let's go Queen c7
he's a little bit vulnerable Knight g4
possibly let's look for this d5 break
now okay take towards the center secure
my knight let's strike it h2 I really
just I'm doing this because I want to
exchange dark square Bishop so I can
rely upon my knight as a very good
defender from
my kingside this square covered just run
a castle there should be seven super
defender here super defender defending
h7 strike at b2 a really good play
against their queen side why didn't I
take that because I would have ended up
into Bishop takes discovery I'll just
double up on the only open file King f8
is a nice improvement let's trade be
careful about that night be careful he
might get trapped if he goes in here how
about I improved my night position let's
get there and night here no let's do
that snake d6 yeah ninety-six let's just
get rid of that pesky knight Knight d5
probably no okay now I could focus on
this pawn I could have also taken on f4
let's break oh oh you could take a rook
don't be afraid to take a look next time
rook takes pawn I have mate its mate
back to tournament 36:30 2822 I did the
chest girl with straw 94 I guess or
maybe a connection issue all right let's
go Queen b3 I'm on b7 maybe get the a
file okay they're running in Reverse
let's keep my knight here that's a mouse
lip I wanted the D file and here I might
want to consider taking like that mm-hmm
let's keep the Knights on board they're
lacking some space Queenie to be for I
don't want to take care I feel like I
helped their pieces if I do that the
b-pawn wreck or
hmm okay and see that um Bishop here now
they have Queen takes pawn though and
this is a good move I'm pretty sure whoa
what's up with that
oh really you're giving up your dark
square bishop I don't believe it I don't
believe it
let's just trade and grab this pawn I
guess okay now there to getting that
insert this check get active yeah let's
keep some pieces on the board King F two
on the bishop on the pawn if they take
on c3 okay I'm on the bishop again a
knight on board he's worth a lot in
blitz it's definitely worth a lot in
blitz extra tricky they're down on time
forty thirty two twenty eight all right
let's try something other than Knight f3
huh less than three minutes left in this
one a Carroll I guess we'll go for an
exchange
let me restricter light square bishop
mmm that's one of those half developing
moves Bishop d7 all right
I go for d5 break giving me their dark
square bishop
I want my dark square Bishop there
they're really moving forward well Wow
all right let's get my bishop here Queen
on g4 stop stuff against g2 and Knight
here's a nice move
I'm also striking at c5 I could also
consider taking the night let's do that
and get here
stop v5m hmm I guess we'll just double
that was a bad idea huh King on f2
they're playing really fast really
really fast okay
thank here Knight takes pawn to check a
fork in there take their Bishop let's
just give a check real quick
could take here I guess no right here
mmm it's a one King and pawn ending and
I should have this though King over it's
it easy it's easy to get some pre moves
and now oh that was a bad one mouse
little mouse slipper uh-huh sneaky come
over here
defend the rook and push your pawn to
victory lane there you go that's the way
forward
you got it back to tournament 44 what's
what is going on - with straws 4440 that
doesn't make sense maybe he accidentally
withdrew 4440 28
84 players yeah he's back in yeah it's
gonna say only a 4-point difference here
we might get paired up again oh no we're
not gonna get paired up again I don't
even look at the tournament time
tournament is over
ah how do you like that that one finish
fast and those 26 minutes flew mmm all
right final standings 44 44 40 28 26
25:24 let's go through all the pages
here I've been forgetting to do that
page two three four tsunami fonts five
no no fries revenge what a creative name
almost there
did I see alpha-strike I think I know
who that is and that's the final page
all right
twelve to start and by the end
eighty-four to the eighty four of you
good games all alright
you